salut les menthe à l'eau dans la vidéo
numéro 112 du mental blog je vous avais
demandé ce que vous pensiez du
mentalisme en termes de clichés quoi ce
qu'est ce que ça vous a mené comme image
dans votre tête vous m'aviez répondu des
trucs parfois pertinent rarement vous
êtes plutôt souvent what the fuck
alors aujourd'hui voici la définition du
mentalisme la version du dictionnaire
ces approches dont le but est de cerner
le fonctionnement de l'esprit humain en
particulier la conscience notamment par
l'utilisation de la prospection la
paternité du mot mentalisme bien d'un
philosophe anglais de la fin du 19e
siècle qu'il avait utilisé pour
l'opposer complètement matérialisme
celle inverse
mais en même temps on trouve le mot
mentalisme dans le domaine du spectacle
des arts du spectacle jean eugène robert
houdin avait écrit dans un livre comment
on devient sorcier plein d'expérience
sur la prestidigitation de l'esprit on
pourrait aussi appeler ça la magie
mentale
au final je vous faire une révélation le
mentalisme c'est tout ça et c'est rien
du tout en même temps parce qu'il n'ya
pas de définition précise personnes
s'est positionné pour dire voilà ce
qu'est le mentalisme ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui chaque mentalist a sa
propre définition du mentalisme c'est un
espèce de mot fourre-tout un sac fourre
tout on y met ce qu'on veut à
l'intérieur et c'est pour ça que vous
allez trouver des médiums qui disent
qu'ils sont mentalist des voyants qui
disent qu'ils sont mentalist des
comportementaliste qui disent qu'ils
sont mentalist mon boulanger dit qu il
est mentaliste
je taquine un petit peu mais c'est vrai
on peut tout se dire je suis mentaliste
est très facile de s'autoproclamer
mentalist c'est un petit peu ce que j'ai
fait d'ailleurs j'ai utilisé ce mot là
pour mettre mes compétences derrière ce
mot de ma bibliothèque j'ai plein de
l'île de mentalisme qui traite du
mentalist d'une manière différente
d'ailleurs je vous ferai vraiment une
vidéo sur ma bibliothèque
un jour peut-être même deux vidéos ou
trois vidéos j'en sais rien mais je vous
donnais ma définition du mentalist
comment moi je pratique ça et comment je
visionne mon mentalisme
ça veut pas dire qu'elle soit juste pour
tout le monde ça veut juste dire que
c'est la mienne et que tout ce que vous
voyez c'est en cohérence avec ça alors
je considère le mentalisme comme quelque
chose
issu de la prestidigitation pourquoi
parce que la prestidigitation c'était
déjà la connaissance de l'autre c'était
déjà savoir détourner l'attention
psychologiquement d'une personne et
c'est fait pour bluffer les gens tout ça
ça se rejoint donc il ya une partie
illusionnisme on va dire dans mon
mentalisme j mais aussi des principes de
psychologie puisque dans tout rapport
qu'on a avec les autres on est obligé de
s'intéresser à la psychologie et moi je
m'intéresse énormément donc tout ce qui
rentre dans le domaine de la psychologie
je le mets dedans
de fait en lien avec la psychologie tout
ce qui concerne l'ain
lens je le mets dedans aussi dans le
mentalisme ça veut dire aussi que je
m'intéressais des choses très variées
comme l'hypnose ou même comme des choses
un petit peu un petit peu borderline
comme la chiromancie c'est la lecture
des lignes de la main la chiromancie
dérobant quoi qu'il repense ça veut pas
dire que je crois dans la lecture des
lignes de la main ça veut dire que je
trouvais intéressant de savoir comment
on pouvait peut-être manipuler quelqu'un
ou voir l'effet barnum agir réellement
sur quelqu'un ou peut-être me confronter
à la constatation que ça fonctionne
c'est une approche en fait très
pragmatique d'un savoir qui a ses règles
donc je me suis intéressé voilà mes
domaines d'intérêt sont du coup très
large pour ma culture c'est pas
forcément que je crois en tout ce que
j'étudie mais j'étudie beaucoup jeu mais
aussi dans le mentalisme tout ce qui
concerne la mémoire tout ce qui concerne
la manipulation des maths et la
visualisation d'une manière générale
parce que tout ça est interconnecté pour
faire beaucoup plus simple pour moi le
mentalisme c'est déjà de s'intéresser à
tout ce qu'on peut faire avec son esprit
et à comment fonctionne l'esprit de
quelqu'un d'autre
donc de fait de s'intéresser aux autres
voilà donc ma propre définition qui
n'engage que moi évidemment puisque je
les crée pour moi sur mesure et ça vous
aidera peut-être à comprendre mon
approche dans les vidéos ou un spectacle
demain je vous fais une petite vidéo sur
le non verbal qui j'espère va vous
plaire
mais ce n'était pas celle qui était
prévu j'ai besoin de vous j'ai une
question à vous poser
au tout départ de la chaîne je faisais
régulièrement des blogs et après je
faisais un par semaine les blogs et puis
là ça fait 15 jours que je dois sortir
un blog sur le festival facéties que
j'avais fait avec les l -g j'arrive pas
à le sortir parce que je vois dans les
stades que le vlog les blogs d'une
manière générale c'est ce que vous aimez
le mois alors je vais vous mettre un
truc un sondage pour savoir si vous
voulez que je continue à faire des blogs
ou pas prenez quelques secondes pour
répondre à ce sondage là ça me permettra
d'y voir plus clair et de faire toujours
du contenu adapté à ce que vous voulez
vous si cette définition du mentalisme
vous a permis d'y voir plus clair faites
le moi savoir en laissant un petit pouce
en l'air est déroulé également le
descriptif de la vidéo je mets plein de
choses dans le descriptif et souvent
dans les com vous me posez des questions
dont la réponse est déjà dans le
descriptif et puis bien sûr
abonnez vous puisque le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc
rendez vous demain à 17h chao je joue
mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre
à la garenne colombes c'est la date la
plus proche de paris si jamais vous
voulez venir sinon il ya toutes les
dates de tournée sur mon site